el ambiente era un poco nostálgico en
las calles de parís 700 coches antiguos
se dieron cita para una gran travesía de
la capital para el deleite de los
transeúntes tiene un lado nostálgico
pero es hermoso todo parece como si
fuera una tarjeta postal siempre es
agradable ver especialmente cuando eres
joven es otra época la travesía de parís
en coche antiguo es un éxito en cada
edición pero este año los organizadores
tuvieron que adaptarse a las
restricciones sanitarias normalmente
tenemos gente del extranjero este año
vamos a tener tres belgas y a alguien de
luxemburgo las restricciones sanitarias
han bloqueado un poco el evento tuvimos
que dar un paseo por el arco del triunfo
no estaba autorizado pero estamos
contentos de poder hacer este cruce
porque dadas todas las incertidumbres
que existían hasta el último momento nos
preguntamos si podríamos hacerlo lohan
compró este fase el 'vega en 1964 hace
35 años pero conducir en parís con este
tipo de automóvil podría estar prohibido
a partir del primero de junio
y deben dejar de clasificar a la gente
no es porque nos apasionan los vehículos
antiguos que no nos preocupa el futuro
del planeta recorremos unos 1000
kilómetros al año representamos el 1 por
ciento del transporte casi no tenemos
diésel en los automóviles por lo que
prohibir nos conducir no tendría ningún
impacto en la calidad del aire
a falta de un maserati o un aston martin
algunos entusiastas prefirieron tomar el
transporte público para ir a todos los
rincones de parís y reunirse con los
amigos a la hora del aperitivo casi como
en los viejos tiempos